in five four three two one welcome you
stupid [ __ ]
welcome to the genius brain podcast uh
this is not a special guest this is the
co-host we have Joe [ __ ] Jitsu
Kawa what's up mother peep-bo hello
hello hello you guys didn't know about
this so like how this podcast is going
to work it's interesting because when
obviously I had this part with myself
but the other half is gonna be with me
and Joe together and yeah man it's
always fun doing [ __ ] with friends
always man people say don't do business
with friends and that's because you're a
piece of [ __ ]
I know I've always heard that -
everyone's like don't do business with
family and friends you know in
relationships I want to ruin
relationships I do you know why it's
because it's like when you you get to
see the true side of them yeah and then
through the struggle you actually bond
more alright yeah you know it's it's I
think that advice came out for not to do
business with friends just because I
think a lot of people don't know how to
do business that's true people come in
hyper confident confident about their
business abilities yeah and that's where
things become [ __ ] up yeah and what I
found out through my parents is that
when my parents were fighting a lot when
they were younger it always had to do
with the fact that we didn't have money
yeah when you're strapped for cash like
stress levels are right and that's where
the fresh that starts to [ __ ] up a
little yeah and if you think about it
like for hundreds of years
family businesses was the norm yeah like
you know like the whole family does the
farm together the whole family they're
like a family shoemakers or whatever
like like father to son passing down
trades and [ __ ] like that like that was
normal family businesses was the norm
and friends that live in the village
together get together and work it's like
that's normal
yeah what we do now today like just hop
from job to job that's that's new you
know a lot of god I had one business
venture that I didn't do with close
friends and that was the one that did
the worst surprisingly really was the
exact opposite so the one business
venture I did based on you know me
believing in the product and adding my
marketing ability to it is the one that
didn't do that well
you know which one it is man yeah yeah
yeah you know there were your friends
they weren't your friends well one of
them was yeah yeah man you know I got
kind of duped into believing all the
[ __ ] that he was saying right and so
what happened with that business and and
me as a person I I kind of like tell it
like how do you know how I am to me it's
not a failing business by the way yeah
it's not a feeling bit but you had a
falling out it's a failing business
because I can't get along we have
partners I don't even meet none of the
partners got along yeah and long story
short with with this with this small
business all the partners are splitting
up because they all hate each other's
guts you know and and my thing was like
the biggest thing that I told them was
listen I'm not here to do the day-to-day
so if you guys cannot get along you guys
have to get you guys have to get rid of
this because you have to like this job
because owning your business is
difficult enough as it is
yeah and if you're coming in every day
hating the people you're around it's not
going to work and so like I alternate
Lee had to make that choice and tell
them you guys need to get rid this
business like it's not going to work it
doesn't matter if it's profitable at the
end of the day you guys are gonna end up
suing the [ __ ] out of each other true
just so toxic yeah just split move on
since you guys think that you know
better than everybody else you guys can
all split take the money and then go
start your own business and see who
really knows what they're doing that's
true we could really see that you know
and so one of the partners because I
made the mistake in believing everything
that he was saying what happened was
that he basically number one he stole
from the company number two he lied
about his knowledge about how much he
knew about things and so for me the
other partners were are very nice and
they're very gullible and so what I said
was like for example I would ask him
something like this right hey man so how
come the machine's not working and he
goes oh it's because of this and I know
the Machine and I'm like that's not the
reason he just made that up yeah I said
why did you say that you know and then
he would expect me just to be like oh
okay and move on but because it's
important I go yo I don't think that
sounds right let me look it up real
quick yeah look it up on the phone I was
like that's not the reason why did you
say that he goes oh no that's not what I
meant
am i okay you caught him laughs so you
know that was that was the first like
fishy thing for me and I'm okay that's
fine and then like let's say like a
coffee machine was broken or some [ __ ]
and
and it when it come out right I'm like
hey this isn't working you said you
would fix it three weeks ago why is it
not fixed yet oh it's because I ordered
the part cool let me go check I don't
see any transactions on the card it
would be like some [ __ ] like yeah and
then I would take them aside I was like
hey one of the things that we need is
transparency and honesty yeah if you
don't know how to fix something just say
I don't know yeah what's so wrong with
that yeah I'm not gonna look at you I
don't know everything we have to figure
this out together we're partners yeah
and on top of that we're friends so yeah
I'm not [ __ ] on you to embarrass you
in front of partners you're lying to me
yeah stop lying to you
just just say you don't know and we're
good homey like don't worry about that
[ __ ] and it got to that point to where
his lies kept building up over and over
and over and white lies or whatever but
when you're doing stuff with business in
this with the way the company works yeah
you can't lie about [ __ ] like that dude
that's the stuff that started pissing me
off you know what my favorite one is
about this partner when he faked a
seizure oh my god that is the funniest
[ __ ] I've ever heard in like just out of
business partners in the hill you know I
cannot make this [ __ ] up dude this was
like the final straw
so he understood how much I disliked his
lying like it was to the point where he
was saying like he was so busy doing
work and I would look over his shoulder
and he's on Instagram looking at girls
and like bro what the [ __ ] does that
have to do with work right now and he's
like busy looking at tennis you know and
so call the partners meeting and the
reason why we wanted to call this
partners meeting was because we were
essentially gonna tell oh look you
haven't been fulfilling your
responsibilities on top of that you've
been misusing the credit cards you're
gonna get kicked out that's [ __ ] so
you're gonna get kicked out either that
we could you know pursue legal [ __ ] yeah
that's gonna be a whole ordeal you don't
even have money yet to go ahead and hire
a lawyer so I don't think you want to
play this [ __ ] game so and plus
evidence Neal email threads whatever
everything is on our side yeah so it's
not a battle that he wants to go and so
he was like I called the meeting to talk
to him about it
yeah with the other partners and then
the day of the meeting he doesn't show
up just disappears but where the [ __ ] is
this guy and he comes up and the other
part is like yo he had a [ __ ] seizure
I was like he had a seizure and because
he lied so much I'm like does he really
have a seizure so our other partner
decided to call one of his family
members yeah and he calls it his sister
yeah he goes you know did you know that
he had a seizure and she goes he didn't
have seized what are you talking about
she goes yeah he has
he said he told us that he missed the
meeting because he had a seizure he went
into a liquor store he passed out and
his mom was next to him and she took and
thank God she was there because she took
him to the hospital that was his story
that was his story and so called a piss
sister and she goes no our mom's in
Chicago so the [ __ ] used his own
mother as an excuse perpetual and child
because he didn't want to come to a
meeting because he was afraid or did it
want to hear about the stuff that he was
[ __ ] up on dad that was the last
[ __ ] straw and then after we
confronted him about it I didn't do it
but the other partner said because I was
so [ __ ] angry I was scared that I was
going to knock him out they were like
okay this is how gullible some of my
partners are right and I don't know if
it was because they really believed him
or they just didn't want me to [ __ ] his
ass up yeah but they were just like okay
well he said that he was so delusional
he just made up the mom part and that he
really believed it that's not that's not
are they enabling and and that's what I
don't understand it's like it's just a
lot of bad personality traits that
aren't like they're not mature yeah
they're not mature enough and strong
enough to deal with business yeah it was
you know I only I can only blame that
individual you know and I asked the
funniest [ __ ] though it's like what
grown man like lies about being in the
hospital so they don't have to show up
to a meeting 100% and then we said some
[ __ ] like this where I told him I like
you tell him because he doesn't want to
talk to me he keeps dodging my calls ask
him for the hospital bill we'll pay it
if it's real I'll pay for the [ __ ]
hospital out of my own pocket
you don't know bro what the [ __ ] are you
a [ __ ] adult you know and so you know
they got they got basically duped into
this thing and so I became the dude that
seemingly seemed like the bad guy yes I
was gonna call him out yeah and to him
he's like he's stirring my stirring up
[ __ ] you're stealing from us you know
you're stealing out of my own pocket
and there's so how does a gullible
issues they want to believe the best in
somebody so much I was like but facts
are facts
I think they avoid conflict at all costs
probably you know that's private that's
one of the biggest reasons why people
can't do business yeah
is because they're afraid to be
completely honest with each other
they're afraid to look a certain way so
they chase they're like lies and [ __ ]
and I think the biggest reason is
because no one knows how to like resolve
conflict that's the biggest [ __ ] yeah
like people just want to win yeah they
don't want to resolve in like figure
[ __ ] out like you're gonna have
disagreements that's just a relationship
right yeah but I think a lot of people
don't know that they didn't they can't
do that so they can't do business and
they blame other [ __ ] like oh yeah you
shouldn't do business with family you
know it's because the the [ __ ]
economy is bad or whatever they have all
these [ __ ] excuses but they they they
they seldomly look at themselves and go
like well I'm kind of stubborn and I
don't like to work with people cuz I
want it my way like no one ever says
that [ __ ] yeah
but that's usually what it is I would
love to do business with family because
if you [ __ ] about to beat you up and
sleep like [ __ ] three-year-old style
I'll go to your room and I'll [ __ ]
piss on your [ __ ] pillow you [ __ ] I
would love to work with my mom dude
because she would work for free you know
even for one of the businesses like that
we were doing like it was great because
there was a family aspect to it yeah and
one of our partners their parents who I
love to death they came in on their own
time and they helped us out that's dope
dude and so and that's something that
that dude that decided to you know [ __ ]
us over yeah wasn't even putting into
consideration like though we have people
who are willing to work for frees
because they believe in the dream and
you're over here [ __ ] around yeah and
for him is I'm not him he thought it was
hard work yeah but so selfish it's it's
selfish you know and it is my until this
day it's he's probably either ashamed or
he won't admit that he's wrong so he
just disappeared just disappeared he
never everytime he responded to my feels
dough I've been so busy [ __ ] you're not
[ __ ] busy I know what goes on the
[ __ ] business you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I love how business brings out a
person's real personality - yeah like
you got to face yourself and you have to
face like exposing yourself to other
people because it's gonna come out yeah
and and the great thing is - and it's a
good and bad thing because say what you
want like they at first hated me
but they definitely have to thank me
later because if this continued they
would have lost everything I would have
lost everything yeah that's true you
know and just because they wanted to
what I wanted to see the best in him it
doesn't matter yeah this is his business
friendship is friendship and even on a
friendship level he [ __ ] up yeah he
[ __ ] up even more on him
you just don't lie to your friends in
like balance yeah doesn't make any sense
yeah no one should do that we call that
you shouldn't worry your friends and say
like yeah I just almost died because you
didn't want to go to a meeting that's
some [ __ ] [ __ ] that yeah and like
you know even you know what JK news has
changed so many times right and we have
had to constantly make adjustments yeah
and there has never been a moment when
there was an adjustment made and I
always thought well I don't think that's
what it's just like let's go let's go
all trying to do it together we're doing
it together there has never been a point
when we've done JK news together for the
past like 7 years where I thought I
don't like this it's like alright let's
try it out yeah it's good to go let's
give it a go it's so like when you work
with a lot of other partners you felt
that a lot where there was a lot of like
no I want it my way it was this this is
the only one it was the one time I did
it with a few people I didn't know I see
and I that's why I don't believe in the
whole you don't do business with friends
do you just have to be particularly
those friends are right I mean like all
of the businesses that I do they're like
from people I've known for over decades
yeah you know like like all of our
restaurants the partners except for the
other two like the first two Jeremy and
Anna yeah I known them since I was in
high school yeah so that's like 15 years
of friendship a hundred percent and I
know what they're capable of not because
I did business with them before but
because they already run a business on
their own yeah they do a lot of [ __ ] and
it had the pedigree for it yeah yeah and
just by hanging out with them you could
tell yeah they have a good head on their
shoulders
if you guys so the our partners are
Jeremy and Jun and Dan yeah they're
probably the nicest human beings I've
ever met in my [ __ ] life I feel like
a stain next to them sometimes they're
so [ __ ] nice man you know Jeremy and
Anna when I would say they came and they
bought me chicken soup dude none of you
[ __ ] everyday definitely I don't you
guys were eight years you sons of
[ __ ] they [ __ ] made me look like
Chinese essence soup and it filled my
soul I forgot how to be human
yo we automated yeah yeah I used to be
like that I used to give gifts I used to
do all kinds of [ __ ] man you know what's
so interesting every time something
would they go somewhere they get us
gifts right right I used to do that [ __ ]
I want to do it too but I forget it's
after the fact that I'm like oh [ __ ] man
if I give it to them after the fact does
that make it look worse cuz Christmas
past and I you could yo give no [ __ ]
gifts man you could even ask Muriel
right like I was thinking like you know
Jeremy Anna Dan and Jun have done so
much for us yeah I want to get them
something right and then it turns out
it's January 4th for Christmas I was
like I forgot again I [ __ ] forgot
again hell yeah they're from sweet-ass
people dude like they're definitely on
some other [ __ ] like every time they get
something for me I feel bad cuz I know
I'm not gonna get them anything I know I
yeah I want you though I want to I want
to get them something we have to do it
together because we haven't been [ __ ]
i I just I just feel weird about it
I don't know why I just forgot to be
human you know because I think at the
time too when we were kind of just
struggling and we didn't have a lot of
money
any small gift meant a lot yeah and now
I feel like we have the means to buy
what we want yeah and we don't want a
lot well what do we really want when
people give me things I feel bad because
it's like we're pretty basic ass human
yeah there's a basic ass [ __ ] it's like
I I need this whatever you know filming
and you know writing and creativity
which isn't which isn't a physical
object you know if they got me like here
here's a ticket to Japan that you could
use whenever that's some [ __ ] but who's
gonna give somebody a $2,000 that's a
lot you know I think what's what's worth
more to me is their time is like if ya
give me your time and we kick it and we
go eat yeah that means more than
bringing back a gift from a different
country I don't give a [ __ ] yeah and
I've been trying to pay for a meal for
them but they keep doing that Korean ass
[ __ ] where they take the bill what I
don't really they keep doing that [ __ ]
so I'm like yo I'm gonna pay you know
like cuz they use the company card that
we're all a part of right no it would
still make me feel better if I did it on
my own
just let me hold the car yeah yeah dude
like I it's a Korean thing to always
want to pay for the meal don't you
better you best get scheduled I sit back
in the day that [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
funny man it's an Asian thing like it's
like you're supposed to out of general
it's it's it gets kind of weird
sometimes though cuz you can tell when
it's disingenuous and it's a dick
measuring contest between the oldest
guys yeah yeah
when Muriel's bestfriend graduated I
went to her graduation she she got her
master's I think it was like an
education or something she ate I
remember
but Becky shoutout to you
congratulations on your masters I didn't
get a college degree so technically I
believe I have a bachelor's just being
around you you didn't you didn't get a
college degree
no I didn't you I had three units left
and I left to pursue comedy good job
yeah [ __ ] job I don't know what I
would have done with a double major and
four minors on nothing I gave a [ __ ]
about dance so I decided to leave and
when I saw her get that degree we we had
dinner after or it was lunch after and
then her dad was going to pay for the
meal and I tried to grab the card and it
was I think I did the most offensive
thing to him because he wanted to pay
for it and I felt bad oh because he's
the oldest yeah and on top of that it's
her graduation yeah he should have done
yeah no chef forgot about that cuz I was
like I'm gonna pay for it is he Korean
he's telling us how many yeah oh [ __ ]
it's like no no no I was like oh okay I
was like I forgot yeah cuz I you know I
was just really proud of her yeah yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure her father would be
more proud of it than I am so I mean so
that's true yeah I forget like sometimes
I forget to do the Japanese stuff too
yeah like it feels so weird you know
every time I go visit my mom or whatever
and then we do the bowing thing and all
that like I was taught all that [ __ ] as
a kid yeah and I had to do it but then
like I don't know like living here I
don't hang out with Japanese people like
it's just I forget do you guys do that
Korean thing where you go
well Korean people they actually put
their hands on their forehead and they
say and you kind of wish them happy
birthday table party party which means
like you know a lot of good fortune in
the new year and so we get on our knees
and we do that to the eldest person in
the family I mean even if they did we
didn't do it okay I didn't do it growing
up yeah we just said happy new year and
then they gave us money yeah I did it
too
Muriel's grandma what do they do what
they like I just haven't I haven't done
in so long because all my weird all my
grandparents croaked a while ago
so I haven't got it in a minute as a
holy [ __ ] this is interesting like it's
been a while
you know since I did that traditional
last [ __ ] yeah cuz my mom said that like
once we moved here she chilled out on a
lot of customs yeah cuz she's like
there's too many damn rules in being
Japanese and she's like when we move
here like I'm married of all that [ __ ]
yeah she's like we have a lot of
unnecessary rules man yeah like we have
rules we're like you have to it's called
India where it's like it's like being um
it's not modest but it's like refusing
when you really want something what do
you call that in English oh it's called
not being a [ __ ] but yeah it's like
it's like would you want some water
you're like no no I stopped doing that
[ __ ] cuz I did that a lot too but you
have to do that now is your pleasure
yeah yeah all the time yeah when you
really want it girls have to do that
especially they have to say no first two
lights time so stupid that's why we
still remember when we when we eat we
just once your food comes out you idiot
well it's bad there'll be some people
that when they kick it with us right and
they're like well wait till your food
comes out and like you [ __ ] eat your
[ __ ] now dude I feel bad cuz I see the
steam going and I'm like man dude like
it feels weird like I want to be polite
I'm like no you're being mad
disrespectful to me because yeah I took
you to a dope best place and now you're
gonna eat it at its least optimal flavor
per se and an Asian places don't do that
they don't bring the food all out at
once like white places yeah you know so
it's like you know eat it yeah I mean I
threw away a lot of that stuff because
it just doesn't make sense for me yeah
like why why should i if I go to a
friend's house right and in they're like
hey you want some water why should I say
no when I'm thirsty ass but my mom she
only did that for when we did church
things but at home she always told me
because she wants me to my mom loves
cooking yeah cooking is her passion and
I think I got a lot of that from her
which is why I like cooking for people
mm-hmm so what the food came out and my
dad didn't get he should give to the
kids first yeah cuz you started eating
it I was like just eat it now and then
fight you know if we didn't eat it then
and then when we gave it to her she got
pissed she eat it when it's hot you know
cuz she is different because you're
supposed to wait right until all the
food is
stay down [ __ ] the custom I want you I
made this delicious ask meal I want you
to eat it when I want you to eat so it
wasn't that weird when you started
eating with us no he made more sense I
don't think I don't have to do the [ __ ]
yeah you know I've always wanted to do
that too and then it's like yeah yeah
[ __ ] it it doesn't make no sense 100% my
parents were always busy was so like
when we went to other people's homes
like I knew how to act right it was like
yeah this is what you do when you're
outside but she's like we're busy so as
soon as the food is made you guys eat
and then go do your homework or whatever
you know when so edrick went to Japan
recently and he got so you cuz so he did
a solo trip bro by himself
yeah he did that solo dolo trip and
that's not something I enjoy yeah I
understand why people like it because
when you travel by yourself you don't
have to wait on somebody else yeah just
do what you want
true but I get lonely I know I need to
share [ __ ] memories and [ __ ] yeah
even if I fight with you throughout the
whole trip at least I shared those
fights with you you know cuz I'm I get
lonely young and then umm [ __ ] now
what's it called he tried to eat by
himself back here and he's like I say it
felt different he said he felt mad
lonely where you go yeah cuz in Little
Tokyo there's like several restaurants
where they accommodate for that by
yourself stuff I kind of enjoyed that
[ __ ] will they give you your own
secluded area mhm I wasn't able to eat
by myself until I got older yeah cuz
before I just felt I felt like oh when
did you start eating by yourself like I
started getting busy and I could give a
[ __ ] less yeah cuz you're just hungry
you gotta eat right yeah like I would go
to a restaurant might I just probably go
get groceries instead because I don't
look like a loser you know and that's a
stupid way of thinking and back then we
didn't have good cell phones yeah so
like now it's easy you just eat and you
just [ __ ] watch a show or whatever
yeah just listen the genius brain
podcast yeah but back then it's like
what do you do you just eat food and you
spaced out yeah that's what you would do
or you would read the paper which is
what I used to see a lot of people do
they open up the newspaper act like man
just to just to get rid of that awkward
feeling of being alone yeah I usually
just stare to space and daydream dude
that's why I would get this chair where
you look out into the window like a poor
puppy buy food and just stare at people
yeah but you're right though in Japan
they have those little [ __ ] kiosks
yeah and then you could put the divider
and you feel like you have your
comfortable space it's it they put a lot
of thought into how they like section
things off and then in it doesn't feel
like this weird anxious you know what
you do eat alone right like it does feel
kind of nerve-wracking especially in an
open restaurant yeah you can feel a
little exposed yeah like if they gave me
a cubicle yeah you by myself is a
different that it's different you know
it kind of works that was study but we
should let's get into the topic oh man
how long have you been going forward I
don't know like 30 minutes out
personally I don't give a [ __ ] okay
the the topic that I think I really want
to talk about just because it's been on
my mind was a so if you guys know like
Kevin Hart had a lot of flack because he
was supposed to host the Oscars right
yeah and basically like in his past
stand-up and it was a stand-up that I
kid you not like I laughed at it I guess
like first of all you know when we say
these type of opinions and I think when
a lot of people do this [ __ ] when they
talk about their opinion about how
homosexual people should feel about
certain topics number one but you ain't
[ __ ] gay so you could have enough
everybody can have an opinion opinions
like an [ __ ] everybody got one right
but what the issue is I think that I see
a lot is that people who aren't
homosexual want their opinion about how
homosexuals should feel about something
that's important to them and how much
that opinion Wayne just like how why
people try to fight for Asians right and
being racist and I'm like yo I don't
give a [ __ ] if they do the Asian accent
mainly don't talk for me yeah that right
like so it's like don't be homophobic
like a straight guy said that [ __ ] yeah
that in the gay guys like I don't care
yeah it's like your opinion about
something that doesn't affect you you
can have an opinion
100% true 100% right but you have to
basically manage your expectations of
how much your opinion weighs on a
subject that doesn't affect you and so
that's the part where it's been getting
a little weird right and it happens a
lot with like race relations mm-hmm
right so when somebody says like for
example the topic of saying the n-word
right which arguably in our past when we
were younger we used it a lot yeah it
was very different it was it was a
different time I mean white kids said it
in the in the in the most endearing way
possible yeah like everyone said it
Mexican is everybody it was a word and
you know it was like saying homey yeah
exactly you know and times have changed
and
there's like people who are saying well
when it comes out in the song how come
how come I can't say it it's like yo
think about it like this why is it so
important for you to say it you know
what what is the importance right why do
you want your opinion to be so I always
say like let the owners of the word
decide to decide yeah and then now I
feel like there's a lot of black people
that are uncomfortable with it so I'm
like okay well if you guys can't agree
cuz I feel like back in the 90s they
were trying to do this thing where they
took over the word and changed the
meaning and in power and they were cool
with a lot of people saying it or at
least the people that weren't cool their
voice weren't that hurt yeah but now it
seems like within the black community
they're not sure of how they feel about
every some people that's cool there's
yes so I'm like if they don't agree or
they don't know I'm just gonna stay away
from me because I don't have to say it
you know and it's like hyper
region-specific too because you know if
anybody's from that Bay Area like
Oakland East Oakland I feel like in
Sacramento I feel like a lot more people
maybe just because it's so hyper like
culturally diverse like a lot of
cultures mesh over there
that a lot of people get that past if
they grew up saying it right and you
know it's not a universal truth you know
that [ __ ] is just I feel like the is
like a passport that only works with one
area it doesn't transfer to where you go
you know I was like you could be like
the white guy that grew up in a hood and
all your black friends are cool with it
but then if you go out and post
something on YouTube in a black dude
from like New York sees it and he's not
happy with that [ __ ] with it because
he doesn't know you
yeah so that's that's the way I see it
is like we're online now we're not like
global it's yeah it's not like your own
your little block and your own five
friends yeah it's different and so with
the with the whole Kevin Hart issue and
his like homophobic tweet or whatever or
his past stand-up sets he came on The
Ellen Show and so what happened was like
he was supposed to host the Oscars right
which everybody that's some old news and
he decided they said well unless you
give a formal apology you're gonna have
the step down from doing the Oz because
you know what I'm gonna do this he
decided not to host the Oscars and he
decided not to do the formal apology oh
wow
and the his reasoning for it was he
believes that number one he's already
apologized for it right so wait wait
wait going back right the first
controversy was him cheating on his wife
now what's that the completely different
right okay so the recent thing
I'm just getting caught up in all this
cuz I don't I know there was this recent
[ __ ] that we're talking about right now
is the homophobia thing yes okay so
there's there's two different things
that went on yeah that the whole wife
cheating thing he it got squashed okay
Kevin Hart handle that very well and
then funny now he's seeing some [ __ ] for
some old stand-up homophobe like 2010 or
somebody did gage Oaks and stuff yeah
okay you know a couple of like a jokes
here and there and then you know people
who are gay you know took offense to
that yeah I say a majority you know a
lot for what I've seen from my tweets
and [ __ ] which is super anecdotal I'd
say like it was like 70 to 30%
outrageous right 70 percent outrage
thirty percent were just like I
understand the joke anything that's like
pre 2014 I think should get a pass some
different times you know yeah his thing
was like I apologize I addressed this in
multiple occasions and he goes he
believes that if he has to do this
formal apology he's just giving it the
trolls right that they want to take him
down I agree and so that that's the
reason why he decided to step away from
it and he actually used Ellen's platform
to talk about it again so he went on The
Ellen Show The Ellen Show and an Ellen
what happened with Ellen was he had a
conversation about it and he said that
he's a different person then and now he
explained a situation Ellen says like
you know as as a person of the gay
community like for me like I I accept
your apology and I think you should be
allowed to host the Oscars which was
kind of cool but check this [ __ ] out
dude there's a second backlash from that
there was because so Ellen got in
trouble too or what a little bit yo so
so check this [ __ ] out so I'm not sure
if she got in trouble per se but there
is even a split and a division within
once again we're not gay so I don't know
about this stuff
until somebody brings it to life where
there's a cultural like a racial divide
within the gay community like for
example like the black gay community and
the white gay community is also
different and so black gay Twitter or
social media people were even saying
like yo yeah we are homosexuals but we
want that apology wasn't really there
and Ellen isn't a spoke person from the
black gay community
cuz that's the one that Kevin Hartz kind
of representing we're kind of tearing
down right now because homo homophobia
is so huge in the black community yeah
huge like what's his name he's a woman I
think he's a fox news Don Lemon or I
don't know but he was he was talking
about how it's it's different you know
in the play yeah I mean in one of my
social psychology classes we were
talking I learned about how the black
community is pretty homophobic yeah and
it's to the point where there's this
code called like being on a down-low
yeah we're like guys are actually gay
and they can't admit that they're gay
but they but the but the safe place
where they can be gay is in jail yeah
yeah so they they purposely commit
crimes
so they can be gay in jail yeah now I
was like that's so [ __ ] sad dude like
you're not a criminal but then you want
to be what your lover's so bad that
little [ __ ] do a crime just so you
could be openly gay in jail like that's
crazy
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] that's crazy like
literally they could say you know I
killed for that [ __ ] big they
actually did [ __ ]
that's a wild [ __ ] nuts man you know
it's like the booty hunter you know the
booty other like booties more precious
than water
yeah what did that fool say in prison he
was like he goes if I see that ass I'm
gonna get that ass yeah he's like I'm a
warrior he's like he's like I just walk
up to foods and I'm like I want you you
sexy and I need you the easy way or we
could do it the hard way
this was like he was like he goes yo how
these junkies nonino they walking around
with the pants saggin that's just nice
booty for me to see the booty hunter bro
what I see is a very suppressed closeted
man that's like super he has to
overcompensate with super hyper
aggressive masculinity and like you
could tell he loves men he's super gay
but he can't admit it yeah like won't do
it he's just so tough about raping guys
like that's so weird like it's like and
it sucks because he couldn't express
himself
that's just so funny dude because it
reminds me of that Dave Chappelle thing
where he says like there's a lot of like
a lot of like duh gas dudes they don't
say like you I [ __ ] like when you go to
prison
they got my prison [ __ ] you say I [ __ ] a
dude in the ass but I'm not
yeah and that's that's like that's what
we study dude is like a lot of these
guys don't consider it being gay because
they're the ones doing the penetration
yeah so they're like if they get
penetrated they think that that's gay
yeah yo that's that's crazy I have a
friend of mine who told me the story
where there was a dude so you know what
you do like mm a [ __ ] and it gets really
physical yeah yeah touchy right yeah but
there'd be some [ __ ] where like they get
super close and a lot of dudes that
fight together they bond together right
oh they go out to a fight or a match
they're all sleep in the same hotel or
whatever but this dude would like joke
around my grabbing dick right yeah and
they knew this dude was gay not in a
sense of like oh he has all were saying
that just because he has to but he would
like sexually harass a lot of the males
so it wasn't like guys being guys like
you know guys being guys grabbed each
other's balls and do all that locker
room [ __ ] yeah but this guy actually had
boyfriends and stuff
he didn't say he did no cuz it was it it
was on that like tough-guy [ __ ] you know
because he would try to so and the
reason why we really confirmed it was he
was saying like yo man I don't know it I
guess they were just chillin he goes yo
man let me ask you guys something real
quick uh uh if I if I [ __ ] a guy in the
ass that's not gay right like and
they're like yeah hold on a second what
you mean like you [ __ ] the dude Mia's no
I'm not saying I [ __ ] the guy in the ass
but if I [ __ ] a guy in the ass that's
not gay like no bro if you have sex with
the male you bet it probably means that
you're gasps no I'm not saying I did but
I'm not why is he being this defenses
you can tell like there's nothing wrong
with babies just he's like Hannah kiddo
but this dude was like no no no like
what I'm saying is I'm not getting
[ __ ] but I'm [ __ ] so I know what
you're saying bro who's like no bro
you're gay just it's cool and yeah that
point to what he would [ __ ] around like
yanking dick he's playing yank a dick
like you [ __ ] like that and he's
basically me to anis nudes around him
but he's doing it guys saying he's not
gay oh so he's just like getting that
out of his system but I don't know he's
like flirting it's but he doesn't know
that he's flirting he's being excited I
was a [ __ ] sexual predator but yeah
and he's playing it off as yo I'm just
to be doing dude stuff we're just
[ __ ] around like no bro you're
[ __ ] sexually harassing these that's
not the same thing yeah
and it's just so funny oh yeah how are
you gonna ask okay it's like yup
what did you expect these people to say
yeah and how do you just bring up in
conversation at a Denny's by the way man
the hold on sec it so I'm [ __ ] a guy
right yeah yeah I mean I could yeah it
kind of breaks the line between like
friendship and like wait a min and I bet
you that's how a girl feels like when a
guy is like he's her quote/unquote
friend and then like he's trying to like
make moves on her when he's that same
it's the same thing but he's trying to
get a past feeling up on these dudes
which is not right homey that's [ __ ]
sexual harrass it is you know yeah and
the difference is that these dudes will
[ __ ] you up like you do it to a budget
MMA guys like come on bro what were you
thinking yo bear you know back this time
oh yeah yes like he got flashes oh hey
man Ellen got flag I guess and you know
how they were putting it was I guess
like Kevin Hart really didn't apologize
and what he was saying they were looking
for his apologies right and I guess his
apologies weren't really apologies they
were more like you know times have
changed like I I wouldn't say that stuff
nowadays and people are a lot more
sensitive so I could be careful about my
jokes and I went back to the joke that
they were talking about right and it was
a stand-up set that I actually really
enjoyed and so he was basically talking
about like how to nip it in the bud if
he goes I don't have anything against
gay people like if you're gay you you
you know you do you like that's your
life I [ __ ] love it but as a
heterosexual male I don't want my kid to
be gay you know and so he was making a
joke about how he handled his four kids
first gay moment yeah and I think like
for me the set was funny because that
said to me when I see it he wasn't
saying that he didn't want his kid to be
gay he was making fun of how he handled
dealing with homosexuality and it was
stupid he was making fun of himself yeah
and that's the that's the part that gets
blurred for me I understand the home of
the homophobic tweets were [ __ ] out
of line I got that [ __ ] right the
stand-up set though was not about him
disliking gay people in his son being
gay it was about his inability to
process homosexuality yeah how stupid it
was yeah that's what the set was about
so that one I kind of say like you're
kind of like pulling at it a little too
hard I can't believe we were
fighting over stand-up sets these days
yeah cuz stand-up or like so art in
general is supposed to be provocative
yeah it's supposed to make people feel
uncomfortable it's supposed to like make
a question and start dialogue in
different ways right like but what I
feel like yes it's causing conversation
but people are trying to shut people up
so that's the difference is like people
don't like what they hear so they try to
shut it down and shut it up and we
always say stuff like context matters
and context really does matter
especially invite people are becoming a
lot more socially stupid yeah and it's
the house as the years go on I think
people are just more more dumb people
are you know what I'm saying - they
don't get it I just don't want here's
the thing man like I just don't want us
to progress or digress as a society
where we are looking for things to be
angry about and that's the stuff that I
get scared of because it's getting to
the point where being angry is cool yeah
and life is too short to be angry like
that I say that when you do stuff like
this - it's the whole concept of crying
wolf sometimes yeah and I'm not saying
like that it counts in this situation
but when you constantly just put
pressure like for example it's like the
whole Trump thing for me I don't know
[ __ ] about politics bro I don't but I
will say this when I keep reading
repetitive articles about how stupid
Trump is I stop reading into those
articles because I feel like I've heard
this a million times before and I blank
it out in my head it just doesn't exist
to me anymore
yeah and that's what's happening people
media sources too are looking for profit
as they always do and they're just
trying to shove negativity in our faces
and because we think it's the hot
popular thing to do that's what we're
trying to profit on and insert in terms
of money monetarily and also social
currency yeah I mean negativity just for
some reason we're so attracted to
negative [ __ ] and it's negativity
without comedy that's right that's the
sad part I like the negative stuff when
it's funny like Bill burr yeah you know
Bethel's man negative but at the end of
the day you're laughing because he's
bringing like a funny perspective you
see that [ __ ] about [ __ ] CK he's it's
going through some controversy again
about talking about Asians with little
dicks you know I saw that - he was
talking about how like Asian guys don't
have little big dicks they have little
digs but then they're actually klitz and
they're just extra big I like what I
heard I saw the whole [ __ ] it was
whatever's it was it was just whatever
joke you know and even that to context
matters because in that case - he wasn't
that wasn't the bit the bit was his
career so [ __ ] ruined now
he's just gonna say whatever exactly you
say whatever to piss people off because
it doesn't matter right that's why it
wasn't the joke on Asian people it was
he was making fun in that stereotype and
how stupid it is and he's just gonna say
it because people don't give a [ __ ]
about him anymore and he's basically
just edged lord shock value guy now yeah
because it's working for him
yeah like he did a tour of his whole
quote-unquote apology tour like he's
he's still he's still like doing shows
yeah I don't know but in a lot of people
in the asian community we're pissed off
about that because they're like you're
perpetuating the stereotype all that
stuff but for me I'm like getting mad
over things like that makes us look even
worse
you know people people might disagree
with me on this [ __ ] and you know I'm
like super proud to be Asian I've always
have since I was a kid like that I've
never once been ashamed that I was Asian
yeah I'm not arguably I probably wish I
was black sometimes when I was younger
but I was never a lot of people yeah
everybody either wanted to be black or
white because there was no one to look
up to yeah but yeah I've never been
ashamed about being Asian and one of the
things that I loved about being Asian
especially as I got older was the fact
that we didn't complain yeah and I think
that we're losing that and we let yeah
that that's so true because I feel like
in the past like the Asian Americans
before us and everybody they put in so
much [ __ ] work like the guys from go
for broke
the first politicians all these Asian
like role models like all these guys
they don't come out and [ __ ] about [ __ ]
yeah our generation in the younger
generation they don't put in the work
man they don't do substantial [ __ ] it's
it's it's about I think what I loved
about Asian people was we always walk
the walk without having a [ __ ] boast
and you know what I realize is like even
some people that I know personally the
ones that are the loudest are the least
talented
I [ __ ] you not like we know some mutual
friends yeah go through tons of
auditions and he don't get they don't
make it or they don't make it in
entertainment
yeah because they suck yeah that's
because you know why I know how they
have no good they don't work on their
projects they don't they have bad work
ethics they don't practice you don't
they don't search and try to build yeah
they just want things easy and then they
want to get paid yeah and and so like
they themselves don't want to wake up to
that and they want to blame like racism
they want to blame all these other
things my friends who are the hardest
working the most successful Asians that
are doing things right they're not
blaming other people for their
shortcomings yeah and and I've seen this
repeatedly happen and I know that like
there is some truth right like there
there there are racists there are people
that hold you back there are things that
are a little bit more difficult for us
than other people that's that's all true
but the people that I know that are the
most successful don't focus on that and
they try to beat the competition a
hundred that's what I loved about being
Asian - is that like walk the [ __ ]
walk and actually do things that matter
yeah instead of going on Twitter and
using eight hours of your day just
complaining and bitching about [ __ ] like
that makes me feel like oh it's because
like I feel like I mean this this is a
bit of a an exaggeration but people are
[ __ ] with being oppressed that's what
I'm saying you know yeah it's like they
would rather have the pity trade and
they want to be like oh well your groups
oppress well my groups oppress - do you
want to do a press measuring contest
Oh homie like what kind of dick
measuring contest is bad dude listen
let's not even play that [ __ ] game
yeah you know and I I really enjoyed
that about [ __ ] Japanese Americans
created for Chinese Americans all of us
like coming together and saying like you
know what you could say whatever you
want about us like think about the
stereotype for a second yeah think about
it in a bigger somebody comes you know I
bet you're good at math okay yeah yeah I
went to college shows the oh I'm sick
retired you're look at me they're saying
I'm Asian male yo I bet you're gonna be
[ __ ] successful that's a bad
stereotype like I didn't for them it's
like
all the pressures too much pressure to
be the best is too much now yeah it's
like come on like ah like it's better
than people expecting you to be a
[ __ ] thief or a crack addict yeah you
rather would you rather have that you
know or would you rather I mean like
that's the point dude is like people
think that what they're going through is
so different and so special yeah and
it's like oh man everybody goes through
some [ __ ] yeah why people go through
some [ __ ] yeah you know what I mean like
there's this kind of thought among
minorities that white people got it easy
yeah it's like you think they don't grow
up in meth addict families that are
below poverty like living in [ __ ]
standards like you don't think they
exist you know like no set of problems
everyone has problems like yeah you know
I'll be it we're talking about like
obviously you know being a white person
in America and being a black person in
America there is a huge [ __ ]
difference we're not even on a macro
scale I would agree yeah yeah percent
obvious kill everybody has an individual
promise - yeah we can't not think about
that I just like you can't just throw
these blanket statements out and say
like well you know we got it hard
because of our race yeah and it's like
shut up yeah you know there's like I
just don't want like Asian Americans to
lose sight of the fact that it wasn't
our parents have weren't apathetic to
[ __ ] that was going on like it I hate
how a lot of young Asian Americans are
[ __ ] on our parents like that's the
hot thing to do right now man like on
Twitter like Asian parents this and that
when we know that we're doing it
ingesting jokes but I will never [ __ ] on
their hard work and you think that when
our Asian parents didn't say stuff when
this stuff was happening was because
they were apathetic no it's because they
were above it they they were too busy
thinking about our future and they're
thinking three generations down the line
it's like am I gonna go down in March
and bang my bongo drums or am I gonna
[ __ ] build my nail salon yeah send all
of my kids through college then my kids
become the owners of this country yo you
know I mean like that's why they want us
to be doctors lawyers and all these more
you know they want us to move up the
social ladder so we can actually make
decisions and be the better member
of community yeah and warning you know
and even think about it like this to my
parents we owned a black beauty supply
store right you don't think that people
came in saying ching chong jokes doing
the slant-eyed [ __ ] or whatever and i
always saw my dad just laugh at it and
you know i asked him not too long ago if
he remembered all that stuff he goes
yeah that still happens and I'm like
well what does he goes she might just
laughs he goes why he goes what what's
the whole point it's petty
he goes it's petty it is he goes why do
you have to care so much about stupid
people yeah you're already above dumb
people yeah dude you know you're already
above them and I am I going to stress
and put my energy on people that aren't
even on my level right he goes I have
great customers who treat me with
respect and we have great relationships
with them and I don't look at the whole
black community as something bad because
of a few negative individuals yeah you
know I just judge people for who they
are exactly what it is I'm above those
people I just move on from it that's how
people should deal with racism yeah I
mean like I get it though because I'm
not above it like high school and in in
college and all that I was like oh the
slightest inch of if I felt they were
being prejudiced or anything if I was
being bullied yeah I think I was extra
aggressive yeah
extra hyper like I'll [ __ ] you up and
not only am I gonna [ __ ] you I'm gonna
[ __ ] up your cousins and everybody so
you'll never mess with another Asian
again yeah because I felt like I had to
overcompensate for all the Asian kids
that got bullied yeah so now it's like
well they think were easy targets I felt
like I was fighting this war for all
Asian males that's like I saw this one
guy get picked on I would jump in I
would jump in and start [ __ ] with him
I didn't care it was about the race and
I think that's that's what brings us
apart right is like it's it's it's like
jail it's like everyone's segregated in
jail by race yeah and what ends up
happening is these [ __ ] tribes form
and then if you see an Asian guy getting
jumped by some Mexican dudes you're
obligated to jump in or else you are
ostracized by all Asians yeah and it
kind of transfers into the streets and
real life that way right like if if you
do see a person
getting picked on you you're supposed to
jump in but yeah we should do that for
all humanity like you shall if anyone's
getting picked on you should do it yeah
but like I don't know man that's kind of
where this world is is is coming to
online right like everyone's cuz got a
fight for each other's team everything's
like this team [ __ ] yeah and then if I
side with anything else besides that
then I'm like this person that's you
become a social pariah base right you
know I mean I'm outcast or like I'm a
backstabber or like whatever the biggest
word right now is you're not an ally
like yeah ball [ __ ] the [ __ ] are you a
part of a Roman military army shut the
[ __ ] up dude you know what I mean like
you're not a part of the 300 out of here
you [ __ ] verbal Spartan yeah for sure
you know it's just a weird space now man
and you know when I see stuff to like
with the whole Kevin Hart situation like
I I get both sides and and the sad thing
is or maybe it's a good thing is that
people are gonna blow this up and
tomorrow it's gonna disappear it is and
it's only gonna be as big as people make
it and at the end of the day like I
support Kevin Hart like I understand I
think it would have been a smarter move
for him just to apologize yeah get it
over with which is what he did does
anyways you know it's like yo brought
like why would you want to take a stand
on this and what I think happened was it
was a miscalculation I think for him he
thought I'm gonna take a stand on this
because I'm sick and tired of these
[ __ ] trolls getting their way well it
wasn't that it was a little it was a
bigger situation where I where there was
a community right now that that needs
your help and you kind of shut them down
and it was the black gay community
because he's such a big spokesperson for
the black community yeah yeah yeah I
think for them it was a misstep and a
chance for him to really help put his
support out there and that's the hard
part of being in the limelight like he
is he is such a big [ __ ] star you
cannot deny that [ __ ] yeah you know and
so whenever he makes a small drop and
upon his ripples go everywhere I mean
it's like he's sitting there thinking
about freedom of speech not being pushed
around as a as an influencer and be like
someone which I do appreciate
I appreciate my damn
what you know the black gay community
wanted him to focus on speaking up for
them yeah so it's there's just so many
moving parts especially with millions of
people watching and and following you
yeah there's so many different groups
and so many people that want
representation yeah I think it's hard to
please everybody and we have to think
too it's like how fair is it really that
fair to him that he has to speak up for
a community that he's kind of not a part
of like why is he the spokesperson for
that's what minorities have to do if you
think about it right like white people
don't have to be the spokespeople of
white people they don't have to be
responsible for each other that's true
like the way we do yeah right like like
I mean in Asians it's a little bit
different because it's like if you see a
Chinese person do something you're like
eyes Chinese Yeah right like whatever
but if they were Korean you'd feel like
personally mmm yeah yeah obligated yeah
to do something or say something or put
them in in check because you're making
us look bad or whatever yeah I got you
so it's I think like same with black
people and everybody else right like
it's like we don't have much
representation so that that one person
has to carry the weight of all of us on
their shoulder and I don't like that
[ __ ] because we're all individuals right
we're not [ __ ] I don't I'm not
Japanese Japanese like I grew up with so
many Chinese Vietnamese Koreans like
Indians but everybody like I'm not I
don't represent Japan and I don't
represent Japanese Americans in that
light like I'm I have my unique cultural
upbringing yeah and we could only
represent our personal stories you know
right and I feel like you know sometimes
too we get flack because people are like
oh you can't speak for all crap I'm not
speaking for all Korean people
[ __ ] I'm speaking for myself man
like me growing up as a Korean American
kid that grew up in Sacramento
California
yeah that's all I'm speaking for yeah
and I have my personal experiences right
and they're like yo some yo some Korean
people do they call medicines yo they
get mad at me medicines medicines
medicines yeah like Internet oh no they
get mad at me man why me I get mad at me
I'm talking to you you Japanese [ __ ] I
know I know because I mean like we
should do a whole segment on this but
yes there's a lot of people that are
just very not cool with the Korean
Japanese yeah and then especially like
older people I would say like over 30s
yeah you know rightfully so that's the
other generation you know yeah I just
don't believe I mean we'll get into on
this on another topic I don't believe in
transferring hate me neither yeah I
don't believe that I think it's up to us
to move past it yeah and then learn from
it yeah it's like what's the point you
remember it
you understand it you understand what
those people went through our people
right and then you move on from it but
you can't you can't to even put it even
bigger right citizens were just citizens
why are they being blamed for what the
people empowered into brainwashing
brainwashing you know nationalism yeah
like that's what's happening in America
yeah I mean if you really think about it
and boil it down right like the minority
team is the Democrats yeah and then
white people team is the Republicans
yeah and if you are a minority and you
believe in Republican values or anything
like that you're basically a white
dick-sucker [ __ ] you know like you're
a backstabber you're just not a part of
the team and I hate [ __ ] politics I
[ __ ] hate it because it treats people
as these different groups of like like
it's like sports it's like different
team members right and you put your
individual identity and ideas not as
human beings it's like oh you're for or
against abortion so you're [ __ ] a
baby killer huh or like you're you're a
woman controller it goes from a zero to
a hundred a lot yeah well don't want to
get to know the individual they look at
the it may be not just like I said I
know [ __ ] about politics but in terms of
like like I'll see this a lot right oh
they go oh so you're a Democrat you
[ __ ] liberal snowflake [ __ ] yeah
right hold on a second bro yeah man oh
you know how do you know so much about
me just from this one blanketed title
right they're like oh you're a
Republican I guess you like shooting
babies in the face yeah what how did you
get and what people don't know is that's
all thanks to Russia too that we were so
[ __ ] divided Oh
we have so many great topics I want to
get into all these things but I will say
before - I meant but you know like just
going back to the Kevin Hart thing man
like I I look I [ __ ] with the guy dude
okay I don't know like how I'll be it I
don't think a lot of his movies and [ __ ]
are funny but you know I went to it like
three or four is the stand-up shows and
I was cracking the [ __ ] yeah you did a
video with them where he's making fun of
your [ __ ] Instagram no do people it's
funny because like you know my friends
come up and they're like yo man what's
it like being friends with Kevin Hart he
is not my friend he does not give a [ __ ]
about me man what makes you think that
he and I are friends you did one video
together you look very friendly that's
that's like that public perception I'm
like yo man so what's it like having
dinner with him I've never stepped foot
in his house I touched his hand once
once I don't think people realize that
level of Fame and like these guys they
sleep two to three hours a day and
they're working [ __ ] 24:8 like like I
bet you after he did that video with you
he went off and he'd shot some other
[ __ ] I did some other media
real talk that dude did that [ __ ] he
came in came out didn't read the script
it's freestyle this [ __ ] y'all got on a
plane and went in a jet went to Vegas
right and these guys are meeting
thousands of people per week yeah like I
don't expect them to remember I don't
expect them to do any it's like they are
in a different completely different
world if I saw Kevin Hart in the street
right now I did two videos with him and
I can't was like yeah what's up Kevin
remember me he goes yeah you wash my car
last week and I bet yeah that's me yeah
he's not gonna remember remember he's
gonna mix you up with ten other Asian
guys exactly no you were that waiter and
there's nothing wrong with that I think
it's just difficult for the average
person to understand the level of what
kind of insanity these guys go through
yo I'm not I don't even know what he
goes to man he's so [ __ ] popular
everybody's either loving him or
[ __ ] on him that's about it
I have a friend that did that was
hanging out with him we have what we
both know him but they were basically
hanging out in his backyard and and they
were playing horse
for $10,000 a shot yeah I'm not playing
that game
$10,000 racked up hundreds of thousands
of dollars within 30 minutes of just
shooting I'll tell you this right now I
play horse with that dude I'm basically
sucking dick like there's no good I'm
not I'm not gonna be making [ __ ] against
that dude Ted that's how ball and you
are were you playing $10,000 horse I
want to do that for five bucks right now
dude yeah we play horse they're like you
know we got $5.00 for each shot I'd be
like [ __ ] you bro Manistee so much
money's gonna be what its gonna add up
yeah that's [ __ ] coffee and cereal
for me you little [ __ ] we're not doing
that
[ __ ] man well anyways guys we're gonna
wrap it up right here and we will see
you guys next time on genius brain so uh
yeah man follow us on instagram do the
damn thing uh and also if you liked
anything that we talked about and you
want us to talk more about it leave it
in the comments below
and if there's a lot of thumbs up on
that topic that you want us to further
elaborate on yeah do it hit us up on
those on those media's and [ __ ] I don't
know how to do this anyways guys peace
bye